σφέδον σε κατάφερε δύο φορές να κελβήσει τη δημαρχία της πάφου υπάφος είναι ήταν ιχειρότερη
επαρχία του δημοκρατικού συναγερούμε εκλογικά και τους είχεν όλους απέναντη τώρα έχει και μια εκλογική
εμπιρία που δεν έχουν πιχειοδησιας μιχαηλίδης έχει τη δημοτη δημοφιλία δεν έχει αυτή την εμπιρία
του φαδον άρα ναι υπάρχουν πάρα πολλά ονόματα ακόμα για το υπουργο ασωτερικόν το κονσταντίνοοάλνο
ακού για τό την πορεί ασινομίζω ότι δεν έχει πολύ λογική να θεωρούμε ότι θα
μπορούσε να δα γιοχριστό δουλίδης καιο κονσταντινωσιο άνο δετ για να είναι ο κονσταντίνος ιβάνου
σημαίνει ότι ο χριστοδουλίδης δε θα ίναι ν σύντοτι το ακέλτι θα κάνει διότι πρόσει
όλή συζήτηση και ιμόνο τώρα μας ζί μας και σε άλλε περιπτώσεις συζητούμε πάντα για
τη δεξιά πάντα για το συναγερμόν εσοστρέεια το ένατο άλλο το ακέλ στην εξήσωσηνη νηνκομματική
είναι ο μεγάλος ασθενείς ααμηλάκα κίνουτα απσω και στο ακέλαλλά δεν βλέπουμ κανένας στο ακέλ
νώ από τους αναλητές δεν κυνίζουμε να δούμε στο αγέλφι να πούμε μάλιστα το ακέλέχει
μια πρότασυν εξουσίας νέ το αγελμπορεί το ακειν δεν έχει ξεπεράσει ακόμα την προεδρία χριστώφια
το γευονός ότι υπήρξε μία πενταϊτεία η οποία όχι ολοπληρ αλλά από το έντεκα πούμε
από τομαρί μέχρι το δεκατρια ήταν κακή για τον τόπο αυτό προ το πράγμα το
αγέλδεν έχει καταφέρει να το διαχειριστεί δεν έχει καταφέρει να το συζητήσει εσωτερικά να κάνε
μια αυτοκριτική ατοβάλιπίσω του και να πάμε παρακατω ρα όσο δεν το πετυχένει αυτό χάνει
πο ωστά και δεν μπορεί να αρθρώσει πρώτασην εξουσίας ρ το πρόβλημα την πολιτική ζωή
της κύπρου σήμερα δεν είναι το γεγόν όσο ότιο συναγερμο σε είχες στρέφεινδιασπάστηκεόλα αυτά που